[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je suis ni solaires sur la
fondatrice de rec norrec une start up
social à vocation industrielle qui
développe une solution dans le domaine
de l'économie circulaire et du recyclage
des plastiques
[Musique]
avec n'aurait que produit une nouvelle
matière une matière éco-responsable qui
remplace le bois ou le béton uniquement
à partir des déchets plastiques qui
échappe aux filières de recyclage on les
incorpore à des proportions variées au
sein de notre recette et on va les
broyer on va les mélanger entre eux on
va les passer dans notre process
thermomécanique pour en faire une
matière épaisse mais fluide qui prend la
forme des moules dans lesquels on va là
à passer quand on montrait des planches
donc des objets bien plat on peut
l'utiliser comme bois à l'extérieur
parce que c'est un matériau
imputrescible et qui se travaille avec
les mêmes boutiques le bois quand on en
fait des objets moulés on peut en faire
des gros objets façon béton ou des
objets qui d'habitude sont réalisés en
plastique pour des usages extérieurs
[Musique]
spécialité c'est d'un côté
bas les masques pas les masses c'est une
opération expérimentale de mise au point
de notre solution avec appliquée
spécifiquement aux masques et de l'autre
c'est la préparation de notre
démonstrateur avec un démarrage de levée
de fonds où on propose à des
particuliers de rejoindre la capitale et
des investisseurs plus institutionnel de
financer les investissements conséquents
pour lancer cette usine
[Musique]